[Music]
yeah and so then I said Ben Shapiro
should be all right oh oh sorry stop
stop we're not technically not live
sorry guys I didn't see you there
welcome everybody is that good dinner no
good good
I mean that's fine
he's leaving
oh I just said Ben Shapiro should be the
first to join us at this table and have
a a uh I stopped clapping I was not I
was clapping before then I was not
clapping for what he just said your
thoughts ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists
you see that as CPAC yeah I saw that
yeah we are of course joined by Andrew
Callahan of Channel 5 game oh yeah the
legend we love him friend of the show
friend of Hassan I mean in great company
guys he's going on tour actually Channel
Five Dot news link is in the description
what are you doing on tour tell the
people pitch it a little bit Yeah it
starts in like three days it's like 45
shows in 30 days it's gonna be crazy
it's pretty much like wow we have this
new movie coming out on December 30th I
think called this place rules and uh yes
we're gonna screen like the first maybe
like 15 minutes of that I have a cartoon
that I've been working on we're gonna
show like the first 10 minutes of the
pilot and then we're gonna do a
moderated q a with a local journalist or
something oh that's great oh we're also
hiring like magicians and battle rappers
on Craigslist
now you're selling yeah yeah oh yeah
Channel 5 dot news C Andrew live
probably coming to a city near you thank
you man Andrew thank you for being here
it's such a pleasure uh Hassan nice to
see you God bless I've been
gone for a week I hope yeah I hope this
episode makes it uh bro I have to
apologize I'm sorry but I have to
apologize to you because first of all
last week obviously you guys know why I
got suspended for a week and the part
that I felt bad about among other things
is that we shot an episode yeah on
Thursday it was up for
like 10 minutes I mean we did it live
yeah yeah and it was a good I really
liked that episode it was a great
episode banger but I made some comments
that probably were not good to make
right after because I just got the
notification that I was being suspended
for a week it was it was about Ben
Shapiro correct yeah I said yeah yeah
yeah and we said he should be the first
yeah to come over for a scrumptious
Thanksgiving meal were you a surprise
ticket man I was I didn't expect it but
I that's the thing is like um
and I and I apologize to you Hassan
because first of all I wasted your time
in a good episode that's [ __ ] up we're
gonna have to cut out the bad [ __ ] and
re-upload it then um but but you were
right obviously Hassan was trying to
tell me like
don't laugh bro I'm trying to apologize
God damn it
listen I've been I've been in this game
for a very long time I've been doing
this for like 10 plus years I know how
the ride operates they're always going
to utilize whatever the [ __ ] you say
against you so you can't you just can't
slip up yeah you were you were saying
just you know it's not worth it and and
I was like man [ __ ] this I'm not
apologizing [ __ ] them and uh
I do feel I'm not apologizing to them
but yeah I was gonna say you don't even
have to apologize for it because it's
disingenuous I'm just saying like when
you have a heated gaming moment like
that yeah you just gotta make sure that
you use super precise language that
people can't maliciously cut out of
context or if they're clip chimping you
which is the term for it when you know
you you clip something out of context to
make it seem like worse than it actually
is devoid of any sort of nuance
um it's so obvious that they have cut it
short you know what I mean you just
can't do like an awkward pause even you
know you just gotta deliver it and I
know this because I've said some insane
[ __ ] you know I've said some things that
I yeah when you agree with the energy
yeah well like when you said uh you know
somebody I [ __ ] then Crenshaw I didn't
even think that was a big deal yeah well
plenty of people did I I got you know I
was getting Mass death threats
um we were talking about did you ever
interact with Dan Crenshaw like did you
talk to him and apologize or no but you
wouldn't because remember he went on SNL
yeah because Pete Davidson said
something about it but that's SNL you
know what I mean that question I was
like such a lib at heart which is why a
lot of right-wingers that you interview
yes buys him yeah because they think
he's like a coward [ __ ] and he kind of
is he's like uh
he's like Pete bootage almost in a way
but further right you know so he's
always like
telling Republicans what they can't do
at town halls and they hate that they're
not used to it so uh I think he cares a
lot about like liberal institutions like
SNL and would definitely want to you
know get I mean he's also he loves being
on TV yeah so he'll definitely go on SNL
he's not gonna come on my show though
he's not gonna come on my stream
um and no he he just cried for like 48
hours in a news cycle about what you
said yeah like actual tier yeah Mr
[ __ ] purple art himself no yeah no
but it wasn't your whole outrage toy and
that's that's like because that one took
went to really amazing Heights I have to
say because it was very politically
useful for them yeah but the thing that
pissed me off about what happened and I
just felt so [ __ ] stupid sitting at
home for this week and I was like God
damn it this was so not worth it this
was stupid but like the people that
created the outrage machine are like
straight up white supremacists they like
literally don't care about you yeah at
all
yeah they're like they're the same
people are like Elon Musk bought Twitter
now I can say the n-word like that
that's the type of people that they have
in the audience they're going Ethan
Klein I can't believe what you're saying
that's so messed up yeah and it's all
[ __ ] it's all manufactured outrage
it's ridiculous but you know it it did
help me a lot it did save me a little
bit like when when random producers and
like you know the the sound guy at the
Young Turks was getting death threats as
a consequence of like my work that's
pretty crazy that's when I was like you
know what I mean this is a part of the
job unfortunately but not to this degree
and I I want to separate myself from The
Young Turks because I don't want anyone
else to be like yeah I don't want anyone
else to get hurt for you know my dumb
ass because I'm I'm gonna probably say
some crazy [ __ ] and I was right I have
said some crazy [ __ ] since then yeah
death threats are chill though I mean
it's no chill yeah I get I get like them
all the time why would anyone give you a
death threat whatever you do I guess
just like made their group lamp owned
their group or something I don't know I
try to not look at it but I get a lot of
anti-Semitic death threats all the time
are you even Jewish no that's what's
interesting huh yeah just they're just
like you know the bigger the bigger the
hair gets that's funny the bigger the
hair gets you could have a graph chart
like hair size anti-semitic online
bullying right just spiking right so my
emails is a lot of those guys yeah
they're yeah they're afraid of the city
though because of like the [ __ ] they're
consuming so they're like I want to come
find you but I'm scared of the West
Coastline yeah yeah it's great antifa
controlled the [ __ ] holes I can't park I
can't park my Ford Super Duty yeah it
works at our advantage yeah we hide in
the cities you'll never find us yeah
yeah unless you're unless you're the
Paul De peepee or whatever the [ __ ] the
guy who did that he was like assassinate
Nancy Pelosi yeah I'm kind of familiar
with like the group that he like uh is a
part of the radical nudists people who
live in Berkeley California he's a
radical nudist well you know and
Berkeley was always
butthole some kind of thing no more like
he works for this
they'll pull up naked like they had a
nude uh wedding outside of SF City Hall
after that seems like [ __ ] no no like
Berkeley doesn't it Berkeley hippies are
like super fringed out and like yeah
during 2020 with the vaccine and stuff
all like the uh Wellness Community of
Berkeley like pretty much flipped and it
became like the hot bed for like queuing
on this guy yeah this guy's a cute
weirdo but he also he turned before then
because I because I looked at some of
his writing um literally writes with the
proficiency of a third grader like just
straight brain melted okay Canadian
um comes to Berkeley uh I just you know
I'm not gonna get into my Canadian
comment we need to dude we need to build
a wall okay wait just Canada not sending
their best well actually that's not true
my theory is either Canada brings sends
literally their absolute best or their
[ __ ] absolute words there's no mid
Canadians I've never been a mid Canadian
either they're like Banger people
they're sick they're sweet they're
talented artists they're they're caring
compassionate or they're like white
supremacist psychos that they got like
pushed out of Canada I guess so they're
like I always wanted to be American so
now I can be American a you know right
okay interesting and we need a filter
it's no Mexico but I'm actually kind of
surprised to hear that so but it makes
sense that these buttholes uh bleaching
Sun people some perineum setting yeah
yeah that's yeah I don't think I don't
think they would do bleaching I think
that stands it's bleached by the sun
bleach by the sun yes yeah uh yeah but I
mean he's from British Columbia Canada
which is also where the guy interviewed
will blunderfield is from yeah another
free thing a lot a lot of crazy people
out there dude that one was that episode
I think that episode changed my life in
what sense I I'm doing it now I hit him
up and I was like hey we need to touch
tips immediately you know no I think it
changed my life because it was just like
I think it gave me
irreparable brain damage yeah watching
this man operate
changed me as a person he's a great guy
no okay I mean you know just a loving
loving person for sure yeah he's dude
his Cranium is crazy I'm surprised more
people don't actually let's bring that
up yeah
no he's anti-vaxx but he's more just
into like you know healing himself
drinking his own pee manhood activation
I love rewilding bro I love that in some
uh circles urine is like the ultimate
Elixir like I don't know how they
decided on that but they just want to
drink their own pee and have a good time
doing it I don't think I would do it
the year you're the Gonzo journalist you
better do it I don't think I drink you
better shoot a stream of urine right
into your mouth if I had a day to drink
a gallon of water I might at the end of
the day give it oh just make it as clear
as possible sure yeah that's not yeah
because my dude was drinking his own
piss in the video and that [ __ ] looked
like Mountain Dew okay it looked [ __ ]
green I don't know how that happens when
you recycle urine bro bro the the amount
of acid like his pee was so acidic dude
it was oh God yeah we're talking of
course about one of your channel five uh
episodes I can't get over the fact
that obviously many people know used to
be all gas snow brakes that's like a
former identity long shed it actually
didn't even take you long I mean how
long ago was that but you're like fully
surpassed yeah I think I'll guess no
breaks ended like a year and a half ago
and there was only one month of uh
Darkness between August Moon breaks and
channel five and I feel like in within a
year's time you surpassed in terms of
like views and supporters and everything
and I just can't get over how those
[ __ ] idiots [ __ ] themselves yeah
so bad and it's just I'm obsessed with
it yeah it's crazy because they your
deal with them was you guys what you
were making like what 25 20.
they were getting 80 of all proceeds
merch YouTube Revenue ads it was 360
deals so everything I did outside of
that too so you know they own your ad if
I worked at like uh Jamba Juice they'd
get 80 yeah yeah yeah that's a record
label deal yeah it's crazy which is yeah
insane that they were like they looked
at the most exploitative industry and
were like we're gonna [ __ ] copy that
that [ __ ] yeah you think they'd hit you
up to to get that Jamba Juice money were
they that hardcore oh man it was crazy
really they didn't let anything
management man and so you went to them
because all got snow breaks was becoming
damn it's crazy all y'all got some
breaks you gotta pulled up they didn't
two years ago and they were gonna try to
replace your ass they tried to no they
have a couple knockoff um channels right
now in my exact style at this point at
this point though like your brand uh
like your style of content
and and I told you this is like a couple
years almost like a year ago at this
point like uh especially during covet
when it was popping off yeah your style
of content it was always going to be uh
it was always going to have copycats
because it's so it's so good that people
see it and they go oh [ __ ] I want to do
this I can do that and I also you know I
had a lot of inspiration as well yeah
but what did I tell you you stand on the
shoulder of uh Giants would you say I
suppose so yeah they're never they're
only they're always going to be the
second best
they're not going to be the whose
shoulders you stand on yeah exactly well
thank you man I appreciate it well I
mean I'm cool if someone else takes the
takes influence from it but if doing
things media themselves creates a
knockoff show yeah it revs me the wrong
way they have two shows festivalists and
hard facts the low subscriber count but
it's basically ran by the same people
who took Augustine breaks away from me
you're giving him clap wait what are
they called no I'm gonna look at all no
just you guys can see like yeah what's
their name uh one's called festivalist
it's pretty much like my early kind of
like work Festival style hippie
interviews at different festivals 1 000
Subs just so you guys can get an idea I
don't care about giving them clutter
enough but it's yeah so this is the same
guys are trying to do a thing here yeah
yeah the thumbnails are whack bro
they're trying to be YouTube and they
got Blake Vapes on there Aristotle which
I'm surprised by yeah he's hosting it
yeah and then what's the other one uh
the other one is now gone but it's
called hard effects oh they took it up
they took it down they stopped uh
whatever making the show because I was
like yo this is ran by doing things yeah
but now I've stopped I'm trying to
manifest as little negativity as
possible I like that you've been
drinking your own piss yeah well I have
such a good opportunity and good
opportunity with me like I have such a
great opportunity with the movie coming
it's like I don't want to spend time
beefing it with people on like a lower
level you're origin above I think yeah I
want to ask you about the movie yeah
sure so you were there on January 6th
you have to watch the movie to see
okay okay you maybe were there or not
there yeah but so when did the uh when
did the idea come about to create a
whole feature film oh it's a good story
so I'm at something called the UFO Mega
conference in a small town called Laflin
Nevada where the Mayor Don Laughlin
lives in the you know Penthouse of the
Aquarius Casino It's a real like crazy
Casino town on the Colorado River on the
Arizona boats fall out yes definitely
like a you can rent jet skis there
anyways
I'm at the UFO Omega conference the
leader of the conference Bob Brown
starts to feel like I don't believe in
aliens oh [ __ ] so he like Corners me
that's kind of [ __ ] up yeah he's like
are you here to make fun of us I'm like
no because I actually do believe in
extraterrestrial life so I'm trying to
keep it smooth but Bob Brown's daughter
is like you're a [ __ ] troll you don't
believe that we've made contact get the
hell out of here so they revoke our
press pass did you believe that they
made contact oh I think we've made
contact no day do I think that Bob Brown
and his daughter have talked to aliens
probably not yeah okay no I I was gonna
say I yeah would you believe we made
contact that's you're a True Believer
it's Declassified
no it's not oh the UAV stuff whatever
let's get back yeah yeah yeah all right
we can Duke that out later in a second
so I'm chilling in the hotel room and I
got a DM from Eric Wareheim which is
like hey man love the [ __ ] uh do you
want to make a show I'm like oh my God
so I get on the phone with him
absolutely his company links up with me
to make a show we pitch uh all gas don't
break as a TV show every single Network
rejected our pitch that's so
unbelievable they were just like this is
two out there like that's surprising too
controversial so then Jonah Hill out of
nowhere emails me and Eric and he's like
I want to take this on as a movie with
a24 really so we film it so did he
direct or produce or what he's the
executive producer yeah wow he gave me
his agent he gave me the lawyers to get
out of my contract with with doing
things media wow break out of that they
buy a 36 foot RV for us 824 does and
then we spend the next like four months
following the stop the steel movement
around America whoa and uh yeah the RV
got stolen by some houseless folks here
in L.A really anyone in the movie no but
it was unregistered so like we parked it
outside of the abso office in Glendale
boom RV's stolen so I'm happy with that
and then yeah freaking uh we pitched it
for like two years finally HBO just
bought it like a month and a half ago so
yo that's the best place for it to be
too yeah so that's so interesting so
you've been work you were working on
this for a I worked on the movie for
four months yeah I've been pitching it
and shopping it for the past like two
years and and and
um obviously I know you're probably
gonna love it but like what can we
expect from it and like yeah it's
honestly like the craziest thing I've
ever made wow that's awesome yeah and
was it just pure luck that you were
there to do it or was it like you guys
had the design you had the budget you
had it how did it come to be the
craziest thing you filmed just because
you had the resources I mean it's the
right time it's a real story arc to it
like this thesis like it has a lot of
structure it's not just like a 15-minute
video designed to like make you laugh
and then think a little bit like it's a
full fully like well-rounded story that
we spend a lot of time storyboarding you
know well put like a different level of
artistry and production into it were you
able because I guess you weren't working
HP all the time but you're working with
Jonah Hill and Apso so were you guys
able to get access to like interesting
people to interview and stuff I mean
because I was like mostly in the
magosphere for most of these interviews
like uh abso holds no way in fact I was
about to say it's better that he did not
it's better than he did it on his own
than like these liberal media production
companies helping him out I think that
my friendships with uh Mega rappers and
Infowars producers and stuff that I
developed along the uh stop the steel
route gave me better access to like some
of the superstars wow yeah I can't wait
to watch that yeah how long is it uh 90
minutes
so the whole feature film that's a whole
movie man dude is this gonna be a red
carpet uh I don't know is that do they
do that for director streaming I have no
idea probably probably yeah yeah talk to
HBO about it brother I mean the rock do
you think the rock doesn't have a red
carpet if he does it direct to Netflix
his house is covered in red carpets dude
yeah
I'm excited to see it I can't wait uh it
sounds amazing I also would you have
personal contact and almost like a
personal religion with Alex Jones to a
certain degree yeah uh not anymore but
yeah the last interview probably well no
I mean what's it I actually went to
Connecticut to cover his uh most recent
defamation trial and uh we had planned
the interview and I called him and I was
like yo you down into an interview and
he was like nah man I don't trust you I
was like why and it's because I used hot
mic audio from our previous interview
that we did the one where he walked off
and he's like I don't [ __ ] care man
yeah it's funny that's what he was mad
about after the kids rant yeah it was
the hot mic audio he was like yeah
honor you have no trust because you
showed because you showed like his
producers beefing with him I think so
maybe he just like that makes him look
bad into his audience because like his
producers are on his side but even his
producers are saying like Broach what
the [ __ ] are you saying kind of like
pulls the curtain back a little bit yeah
definitely yeah because when he walked
backstage yeah you did this interview
with Alex Jones yeah and when he walks
off State because he goes I killed the
children it was me Alex Jones and then
when he walks off stage his producer was
like that's not cool man you got to stop
saying that well I think what he says to
me which is most interesting is he goes
are you liking it he says that to his
producer and so it just goes to show
that like his meltdown was all part of
the Optics to like appear insane you
know as like a defense yeah he did sound
in a little insane though because the
producer was like you got to stop saying
that he's like I don't [ __ ] care
anymore man no I think that that I can't
believe I'm about to say this again
full disclosure obviously I'm not a
supporter Alex Jones but I think that
plays to his Brilliance as a content
creator if you could like divorce him
from the genuine on the ground impact
that he's had on humans lives in a
really devastating way with his
consistent doxxing harassment campaign
that he engaged in over and over again
or or even the you know the other stuff
obviously he's done a [ __ ] load more
than just the defame school shooting
victims families yeah
um
but he is
and I we're not alone in this uh plenty
of other uh brilliant uh directors
including like uh what was it link later
or yeah I mean he he's had him Richard
link later has had him as his own
character in both Scanner Darkly and
another earlier movie that he had made
um like people did see him as like a
brilliant content creator he is but I
think the environment now is
uh is especially ripe for a Waking Life
oh thank you that was the other one the
environment now is especially right for
someone like that to be taken seriously
and then people act out on the uh on on
the way on the insane thing the things
that he says basically yeah I wanted to
ask you how that Alex Jones interview
came about because it seemed like you
had the exclusive I didn't see him doing
any of the other interviews he gave me
his first interview after that's a lot
of respect how did that happen I think
he respects that we're independent
more importantly you know I don't know
he I think he's aware that we're not not
on the same page politically but like
you know he knows that we're we're
funded by patreon you know we're not we
don't have any big corporate backing
maybe that's why his producers have
reached out to me in the past to like
[ __ ] do debates and [ __ ] I mean dude
you should definitely debate Alex Jones
that'd be awesome no I think like the
once the defamation stuff uh
one billion that's ridiculous man yeah I
thought I kind of just laughed when I
when he got a billion I was like where I
mean
I mean they're trying to bury him and I
get it I understand it you're using
civil litigation to uh to to stop
someone from doing something that is
genuinely harmful yeah so that other
people don't try to copy it as well and
they are fearful to you know do similar
things I I get that I mean what was it
that had happened before where civil
litigation
ruined uh I mean your company Gawker
Peter Thiel yeah Hulk Hogan sex tape
yeah there was something else what was
it a really [ __ ] up institution that
was
was like oh girl it's gone wild
yeah the civil lawsuit shut down that
organization which was so [ __ ] yeah
probably a good thing yeah so I mean it
you know it's a tool that's been used
effectively in the past yeah for good
but um so did you reach out or did he
reach out to you I did for sure okay so
you said hey let's talk well he's a big
part of the movie we have coming out oh
yeah has he seen it no he hasn't I was
gonna say there's in terms of the
shirtless workout scene
there's there's a lot in there in the
movie Alex agreed to his shirtless
workout scene where I'm pouring Jamison
in his mouth while he's bench pressing
and vice versa that's yeah
yeah that's awesome yeah yeah it is
awesome no I think I'm really stoked
using this documentary's gonna piss him
off no not really no no I mean it's just
basically raw footage of interviews yeah
I mean it's just who he is a lot of
people get pissed when you hold a mirror
up to them you know that's a pretty
consistent theme that I deal with people
acting like I'm twisting their words
when in reality they don't even say
anything they said all this [ __ ] they
just didn't expect that many people to
hear them say it so they feel like I
[ __ ] them over when in reality I just
have a large platform and they're not
used to the the megaphone right yeah
yeah or even in the case of Alex Jones
like he is used to the large platform
and he does say that [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time yeah it's just that when it
escapes the the uh Echo chamber that is
neatly cultivated for himself that has
been like very successful for him uh all
of a sudden he's like wait a minute I
didn't mean it like that what the [ __ ] I
wonder what he thinks about the uh
Pelosi attack oh great uh well I'll tell
you right now I know what do you say
boss flag yeah at this stage I don't
need like watch Republican commentary to
know exactly what they're going to say
that's why I always joke like I'm like
dude if I wanted to [ __ ] grift I
wouldn't be a leftist like the worst
place to grip I would just be a
republican I'll tell you right now one
Paul Pelosi he was in his underwear uh
many people have said that Paul Pelosi
has uh sexual dealings with men uh this
was probably a lover's quarrel okay my
sources I got the document it's just
Alex jones.com infowars.com I'm hearing
that the the commissioner the chief
commissioner and police in San Francisco
has given me the documents folks it was
a lover's quarrel happening at 5 a.m
Nancy Pelosi if that's what happens I'll
be very [ __ ] impressed
lovers he's gonna say it's a lover's
quarrel uh the the what about false flag
yeah they're not saying the false flag
oh it's either a Lover's Coral or a
false it's false Flag Day it's false
flag to drive sympathy towards the
Pelosi's even though they're vampire
demons that are stuck in children's
blood you've seen those big old titties
on Nancy yeah that's cultivated from the
blood yeah those are baby incubators
she's got a baby in each titty those
cleavage look way too young for a woman
that age yeah her living SF does not
help her case on the false flag front
either you know what I mean just like
that that place epitomizes that
important that it's like the most evil
places in the world yeah of course yeah
which is exactly what Fox News did like
the mainstream commentators and I
[ __ ] called this out immediately as
soon as it happened too as it was like
as they were cutting coverage
um what they said what uh Fox News
mainstream commentator said immediately
was to be like victim blaming you know
this is not our fault this is not like
one of them no way you didn't read this
no David de Pepe tells investigators
that he and Paul Pelosi were engaging in
gay sex and had an argument over drugs
poppers yeah Pelosi's are refusing to
turn over surveillance video of their
home feeling more speculation of
homosexuality at the home to paint by
his arrest for male prostitution that's
a lot of retweets a lot of people think
that okay this is happening David de
Pape and Pelosi's old husband were
hooking fighting over math then argument
ensued over drugs an 84. I think if you
smoke like method 84 you just died right
yeah what drugs can you do at that age
wait first of all Paul Pelosi bit of a
[ __ ] Lush I'm just saying she loves
drunk driving brother oh yeah does he
he's a party boy he's a guild a DUI oh
really which is like impressive it
doesn't make you a party boy if you're
84. and you're getting your parties are
you're 84 years old and you're that rich
yeah you got arrested for a [ __ ] DUI
it's like respect okay at that point I'm
like bro but yeah you know what not to
come across like a drunk driving
evangelist I respect his DUI bro I'm
about to get in trouble again for a joke
let me just say that
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah of course he's
he's like the
attacker's husband yeah no he's going
through a lot man yeah no but he's like
the insider trading that goes on with
that family makes me want to puke I
[ __ ] hate those oh no for sure
they're disgusting nasty humans right
obviously they didn't deserve that and I
wouldn't wish it all right yeah I don't
know but also Paul Pelosi like 84 years
old this [ __ ] dumbass 45 year old
groiper Paul De peepee or whatever the
[ __ ] his dumbass name is a photo of him
out there it's so wait
these are the dumb asses in my [ __ ]
replies all the time who are like like
you know Master race you're just working
for the Jews or whatever and then I look
at their [ __ ] photos and I'm like bro
you look like that shut the [ __ ] up yeah
he he's like a classic like friend
grouper too so he like talks like a baby
I don't know if you've seen these I'm
not familiar a friend World he's like
one of those guys it's a it's an
offshoot of clown world this is like
really [ __ ] inside baseball Nazi [ __ ]
right yeah but some of these Nazis
literally talk to one another like
little children do and they post photos
of what they call friends which are like
the the the uh the cute version of the
Pepe the Frog which I you know we use in
our community as well but anyway so
that's wild he's one of those [ __ ]
guys genuinely his brain capacity is
diminished like it's very obvious reads
and writes like a third grader
um this guy up there he is breaks it and
that's back when he was 33 that's from
like 2013 okay you know uh that that's
the face of a gamergate guy right there
um totally dude yeah he he was a
gamergate guy that's why I said I think
he was before Oh that's why I said I
think he's before he radicalized before
he went on I'm just surprised he you
know he hangs out with like nudists in
Berkeley that's not typically what a uh
gamergate he right like I would do he
seems to have a bit of he might have uh
birth the defect he he uh was cuck he
was living in a house he was living in a
house with a nudist chick and like the
new District's fiance with like their
children and [ __ ] like any officiency
syndrome like Ethan is no no that's not
okay whatever well you know what bro I'm
calling out all fetal alcohol fetuses
right listen you're unnoticed yes stop
drinking put down that bottle you fetus
parents moms stop drinking when you're
when you're pregnant your son might
become a grouper okay anyway the
funniest part about this story however
for me is it is a funny [ __ ] story is
that this guy's trying to pull off a
political assassination right but he's
so [ __ ] stupid it's not like a Shinzo
Abe Styles political assassination which
was very successful yeah right like
literally the entire lives the entire
nation of Japan the entire nation of
Japan straight up was like yeah [ __ ]
Shinzo Abe actually like which is crazy
to think about
um this guy goes into [ __ ] Paul
Pelosi's house can't even find Nancy
Pelosi he's like where's Nancy Pelosi
where's Nancy Pelosi and then an 84 year
old man beat his ass bro he couldn't
even [ __ ] kill a 84 year old man with
a hammer really yes I thought he they
struggled well okay so maybe he wasn't
enough they were making love dude he
goes he goes into the house Paul Pelosi
calls the cops cops come in the police
report it states they watched these two
characters scuffle over a [ __ ] Hammer
cops literally watched this guy hit Paul
Pelosi in the head with a hammer
Wonderful by the way congratulations We
Love Our Place actually there's some A
Wrinkle in this story that was crazy
what so Paul uh Pelosi called the police
as the Intruder was coming in yeah put
the phone down as they were as he was
you know confronting him having gay sex
yes and he was speaking in uh he was
speaking in uh he was speaking he was
speaking in code not the best dispatch
not Nazi baby talk pull up that that
excerpt uh a dance because I'm sure I
read that which is pretty cool yeah
cool of course immediately the [ __ ]
chief of police was like we commend our
dispatcher for immediately assessing the
situation and recognizing it and swiftly
responding to it it's like [ __ ]
you responded and you waited as this
skull was getting bashed in by some
[ __ ] griped up idiot
fetal alcohol syndrome ass having
[ __ ] okay
um let's see probably took the cops like
30 minutes to get there no it's
originated they probably started
throwing coins at him
when they were yeah it's in Pacific
Heights I remember someone did a tag on
their house during uh covet that was
like we need more money listen to this
it was really thanks to Mr Pelosi having
the ability to be able to make the call
and true the attention and instincts of
that dispatcher to realize that
something was wrong in that situation
that's not what I wanted he looks pretty
good can you give me like a more
specific yeah he's hot I mean he's
hitting that dude I mean come on
who wouldn't be who wouldn't be youthful
they're both pretty good looking in this
picture you've seen that Pelosi cleavage
one no oh my God it's not something
you've never seen Nancy's Pelosi's no I
don't know what they say oh my God no
I'm just being honest I thought you were
a journalist dog I want to be respectful
Fox News was running this fox just ran
it oh yeah Tucker's talking about it now
look at that I mean like shoot like oh
[ __ ] let's let's actually hear what he's
I haven't heard this this last Fourth of
July weekend and why not but the beach
in Italy and we're going to go out
tonight by singing your retinas with a
photograph of that event
oh please [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie this
probably improves their approval rating
yeah why would that change my retinas is
Tucker saying this is a bad yeah it's
disgusting ew why because she's an old
lady and she's Nancy Pelosi I don't get
I mean she got some titties on her
there's nothing wrong is there a picture
of Tucker's shirtless anywhere I'd like
to see Tucker's [ __ ] where's that out
I'm sure third in line from the
presidency on a private beach in Italy
soak it in ladies what an idiot loser go
to sleep tonight and try to get the
image out of your head how sensitive are
you bro
Tucker Carlson's audience average age is
like 87. so they're probably like damn
that's a fit Bird right there I mean it
she is though for her how old is she she
looks great I'm popping extra Seattle
right not for that one brother we'll be
thinking about that Italian Stallion yo
how how old is she Dan
uh 82 or 83 or something
come on I still got it she still got it
82 a.m the best night with the ones you
love see you then what a [ __ ]
disgusting she still got it she's good
for her this was a big thing uh so I'm
surprised you didn't hear about it no
I've never seen this uh this happened
recently pops man I mean that's good for
her the horrible person overall but like
that that is a that's a bonus for her
you know um here here you want to send
your retina strikes out here you know
what I'm saying we're unbiased Ginger
retina ew who could ever sleep look at
this guy's [ __ ] chest Bros have you
seen the old picture of him when he's in
high school like sagging yeah with like
a Burberry t-shirt on like yeah his
facing going like this find that Dan I
guess he's SF city boy he's lying all
over everyone he's so funny because like
he constantly shits on liberal arts
Majors it's like bro you are a liberal
arts major dog what the [ __ ] are you
talking about Swanson frozen Food
Dynasty recipient [ __ ] when you're
when your relatives are named Buckley
okay when you have a relative named
Buckley you can't talk [ __ ] about
[ __ ] Elites in America okay you are
the Elite dog he spent half his life
wearing a bow tie enough said about the
little [ __ ] yeah but anyway I'll tell
you I want to go back to the Alex Jones
oh what a d what a little [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] I'ma bully you on the playground
you little [ __ ] no you know [ __ ] you
Tuckers
he looked like the type of dude who put
a little bit GBS and a drink at the
party you know what I'm saying damn
first of all dude what's the date rape
drug called
you're talking about GB gbh yeah
what is it called g-a-g-h-b this man
carries B this is the Frat party you
know what I'm saying he he does look
like uh like a lacrosse boy yeah I mean
he he looks like he definitely played a
lot of Lacrosse with the homies holy
Milk porn exploding milk have you seen
that when he's talking about [ __ ] the
Ontario teacher with the gigantic news
that was like uh that was like another
thing that was like popping on Tick Tock
and then took across and talked about it
there's some [ __ ] troll teacher in
Canada that was wearing these like
man-made gigantic memories like they're
they were that story was pretty wild
they were they were insane for sure and
I was just like but like of course they
cut it up then like this person they cut
it to make transphobic at your prop as
always yo you want to see some nasty
real nasty [ __ ] look at this sick [ __ ]
dude that's disgusting bro I have some
respect for yourself Tucker those are
those are they're not tuck those in that
is just horrific breasts they look good
they look good they look good on Tucker
and actually kind of like what I'm
seeing I'm not sure yeah I think okay
it's confusing me a little bit but I
wanna I wanna ask you yeah I wanted to
ask you more about the Alex Jones gotcha
we went on a far tangible I'm gonna come
back to that
um
you reached out yeah he said yes and uh
you drove to him in Texas is that what
happened yeah yeah I didn't burn him
with the interview you know like it's
pretty raw footage type thing I think a
lot of people when they interview
someone like that they think they have
to be overtly charged with their
questions they end up like turning off
half their viewership by doing that just
try to go in like with an open mind or
at least not ask loaded questions yeah
because if you do that I mean every time
someone interviews people like Alex
Jones or I even noticed when I was doing
the whole stop the steel thing I'd
interview like Enrique atario and like
kind of like people in the proud voice
fear and they would just ask him like
like do you you know like what do you
have to say for yourself you've done
this and it's like you're never going to
get a genuine response out of someone if
you start a question that way right and
so you think any guitar he was a is FBI
you think he's a Fed no you don't think
so not for the six but in general I mean
he cooperated with uh at the FBI for his
um
diabetic test strip thing Enrique atario
I think he's now incarcerated former uh
chairman of The Proud Boys sold two
million dollars worth of expired
diabetic test strips in Miami so he uh
took I think he took a plea deal
uh for cooperating with the FBI for that
case they usually re they usually
reinstitute Ci's like that though like
they will reuse them that's why like um
that's why like a lot of the [ __ ]
dudes that they use to try and
infiltrate like Muslim groups uh like
white dudes that they try to infrastrate
Muslim groups with like they would be
like [ __ ] you know pedophiles and
[ __ ] you know what I mean like they were
just like they would NAB them for
pedophilia for like an unrelated charge
and then they would use them as CIS to
do yeah whatever the [ __ ] I think why I
said he might I think if he was
snitching there'd be like way more
people locked up than there is right now
or maybe it's just not as or it wasn't
as organized in a serious yeah
if you've been in a riot you know it's
like spur of the moment like you know
the crowd gets worked up I don't think
you have to necessarily plan things with
that much intensity so you you went to
Alex Jones studio in Texas and what was
what's it like there when you're really
nice it's got to be I mean they manage a
lot more he made 800 Grand in one
[ __ ] day uh after the the CPAC the
infoware studio is beautiful for rnc's
got like is there a lot of employees
there like what's it like there 10 or 20
10 or 20 yeah
his set is incredible that is like a
super high end I mean we're in a two
billion dollar Studio yeah we are yeah I
mean our game recognized game yeah our
compound's not bad yeah it was one of
the nicest places I've ever filmed and
and what was the what are the people
like there was it inviting was it warm
you know it's interesting a lot of the
people who work for Infowars aren't even
really that political it's just their
job and they just want a job yeah like
the first guy that I met there I'm not
gonna say his name told me he's like a
full-blown liberal he just found the job
on Craigslist and that's where he's the
mall that's awesome that's it that's
incredible that is uh it's got to sit
with you though man like after the some
people just that's gonna do the job some
people their brain works in a way where
they separate their employment from the
impact of their work so much they don't
even think about it
every day look he's not saying
controlling the camera I mean yeah I
respect it I mean [ __ ] it's not like
someone that's gonna hold the camera to
see a good employee do you think Alex
Jones or people that are happy yeah yeah
definitely good employer it's a good
work oh there's actually there wasn't
snack room or actually order barbecue
there's no snack room with infowar
Studio that's a shame that's crazy you
guys have a good snack room there's like
fruits you should see the one at Teddy
fresh it's nuts yeah stacked
it's important they keep me warming yeah
[ __ ] cold Brews you know every time
I'm happy and and so and so you sat the
interview didn't seem to go very long
the the actual interview it was about 45
minutes it's on patreon oh the whole
interview's on page I had to keep it
short for YouTube because I wanted to
keep it like Sandy Hook focused because
that's what like what the defamation
trial was about right but I talked to
him about a wide variety of things like
uh January 6 you know okay 2024
okay so I had I haven't seen the excuse
me the whole uh whole interview but so
when it when he gets pissed and walks
off did you guys end it amicably or did
he kick you out like we ate some
barbecue right yeah you guys it's cool
I'm not a very antagonistic interviewer
so it's kind of hard to end things on a
bad note unless the other person freaks
out
okay so you left friends and then when
you posted it he called you or you
called him or whatever uh yeah he called
me
he called you yelling straight out yeah
yeah for sure what kind of stuff was he
saying just like you know like how did I
thought we were friends that invited you
guys into my space and you used the hot
mic audio on me like you know he's like
that's not what friends [ __ ] do like
imagine if I went to your house and
miked you up and I was like well what do
you say to that as a jerk I said I I
understand you know if someone hot-miked
me uh you know I probably wouldn't be
too happy about it but I think that his
change in demeanor from like the
explosive interview to like the kind of
calm in the back room being like am I is
it working was it important to the
journalistically important did you
explain that to him yeah what did he say
I think that
he didn't he wasn't want to hear what I
have to say yeah you know he was worried
that I was going to dox him if we ever
met up again
so are you so it's over your French
friendship with Alex Jones ended
unfortunately I think he'll come back
yeah you think so if he does I mean yeah
these guys are Alex Jones is a media
demon first and foremost that narrative
shift between him on camera versus him
off camera is an is an indication of
that reality to me that therefore that's
a platform he will always he will always
value Andrew's platform uh more than
like uh the the feelings that he has
towards Andrew do you what's your take
on Alex Jones as someone who's had a
friendship or a relationship with him do
you think he's like a real genuine
person or is there two Alex Jones which
a lot of people speculate I mean he's
pretty fun to hang out with like he's a
good dude to like uh get a beer with eat
barbecue with because he's like full of
full of stories information and memories
he's just you know he's a storied
individual great Storyteller and he's a
great Storyteller yeah he is an
Entertainer I think that at some point
you kind of uh fall to your own Echo
chamber because you know especially when
it's so tied in with Commerce you know
like if you know if you know that you
can get more views by promoting one
conspiracy theory and segue immediately
into an advertisement for like
bulletproof vests backpacks supplements
t-shirts pins hats whatever you you get
you develop this like almost second uh
self which is your media self which has
to be inflammatory has to react a
certain way with skepticism and question
the loopholes and perfectly solid
stories every single time and then sell
[ __ ] and when you're when your whole
like Financial structure is based upon
the outrage machine that you've created
you have to you can only feed your
family by doing the same thing over and
over again you think he starts to
believe it himself yeah definitely I
mean I think there's certain [ __ ] that
he probably doesn't believe but I mean
you know when he first talked about
Sandy Hook like
the the most [ __ ] up thing he did is
have people like Wolfgang Helbig on have
people who run websites like Sandy Hook
whatever I don't even want to say the
name of it but it was a the main Sandy
Hook truth or website back in the day it
has a community of thousands of people
who dedicate every single day to
harassing people like Lenny Posner
families people like you know Robbie
Parker you know people who can't walk
down the street even now without being
harassed and like chased by you know
infowar subscribers they're stalkers
yeah so there's a community of
designated stalkers in our field in our
industry we recognize that because we're
like media figures so we already have
that but like these are normal everyday
Joe Schmo you know what I mean it's
crazy that they yeah have to deal with
it and so the crisis actor crisis actor
conspiracy harassment Community whatever
you want to call it is darker than the
Infowars Community because that I mean
the people who you know go deface the
memorials in Newtown those people are
worse than Alex Jones but it's having
them on and being like go check out this
person's website it's just a made it
away it's just a [ __ ] Rabbit Hole ass
place to be yeah that was Alex Jones
viciously and deliberately platforming
the awful scumbags to me that's the
personal gain yeah you think he regrets
doing that oh [ __ ] it and probably
growing that Community as well because
he has a lot of [ __ ] conspiracy uh I
mean his entire stick is conspiracy so
he has a lot of psychotic people that
are watching him and and you know hang
on every word that he says because they
think he's the absolute you know most
reputable truth teller out there those
guys are now becoming growing the ranks
of the you know even more insane uh gang
stalking Community right because I mean
having questions about sad [ __ ] like
tragedies is a
sometimes valuable like a new value the
police response time why do they take so
long what happened those are real
loopholes real questions real body cam
footage [ __ ] you need to analyze and see
so there is inconsistencies in terms of
like actual [ __ ] that happened but when
you the Sandy Hook [ __ ] was just so
unbelievable and the things they were
saying about it were just so shocking
and [ __ ] up well they do that with
Uvalde they've done that with every
single shooting thus far and I've talked
about this extensively I think it stems
from a place of like
uh exhausting every other Avenue to
counter because like the main problem is
always going to be mental hell mental
health institutions are like lack of
adequate care and also lack of gun
control right
um because you've exhausted every other
uh you know every other counter all the
way to like good guy with a gun
narratives to like arming the teachers
you know what I mean or like giving cops
more money or giving cops more guns
um when you you arrive at door control
yeah in Uvalde or you you need you
desperately don't want to face the
reality so you need another alternative
narrative
and that's precisely why they go with oh
it must be fake it's so crazy that it
must be fake it's almost like a safety
blanket from accepting the reality and
just being like telling yourself a fairy
tale to make [ __ ] seem like it's not as
[ __ ] as it is do you think Alex Jones
is going to survive all these lawsuits
yeah he can do his show from anywhere
the thing is I feel like when you
de-platform someone like that like like
you obviously cut their uh viewership
down a lot but you know the 20 that does
follow them forever onto whatever all
platform is like the most Hardline most
down for you people so he could he could
make a show with 300 viewers on a webcam
in his garage and those 300 people would
probably like die for him well it's not
the it's not the deep I mean he's
already been called D platform he has
his own platform already yeah but do you
think the financial strain of losing all
these websites is gonna ruin him I don't
know man like I don't know about this
whole bankruptcy thing they're gonna try
to do I don't know I don't think that's
gonna work I mean he's farming he's
farming funds off of it he literally
can't but you can't go as far as I
understand you cannot go and be like hey
we're filing for bankruptcy all the
money you donate is gonna go to us like
that's literally bankruptcy fraud he's
doing on TV I think a lot of a lot of
things that this system is designed in a
way to help wealthy people and powerful
people and Alex Jones is a wealthy and
powerful person and he's trying to take
advantage of it as braze easily as
possible it's like the Trump method of
like bouldering through legal troubles
and it is more successful than you would
think like you are more successful
uh you have a better success rate than
what most people would think and of
course if you're like an average uh if
you're like a regular working class
person you're not going to be able to
have any of those benefits but yeah but
then again a lot of people on the right
do think that Alex Jones is like a psyop
really they think they go even whatever
but I've heard from you a lot of me yeah
a lot of trump people they think that
like he says 20 real [ __ ] and 80 like
you know the turning the frogs gay fluff
to delegitimize uh that 20 returning the
frogs gay is real wow so everyone
everyone thinks he's king of Q Anon he's
not most Q Anon people think that he's
like you know trying to make them look
stupid so yeah uh that's ironic because
I think that there's truth and validity
to that statement I do think first of
all the Frog's gay one is actually
really funny that one's true it's not
turning the Frog's gay it's turning
Forks trans technically okay the
chemicals in the water
um but Alex Jones uses that obviously as
a way to say like you're getting turned
gay and that's why you should get my
straws you know and he sells his like up
Mark crazy astrosity cells but
um
Alex Jones of course uh as any Broken
Clock would uh you know is is truthful
every now and then so the frogs are
turning gay frogs are turning trans but
um but that's not one of those things I
was just talking about like the surprise
returning trance tell me more I think
the the frogs uh yes I'm I'm not gonna
deliver additional information right now
okay all right look at it are there are
the folks turning trans yeah I've heard
that Kevin what the chemicals in the
water were uh making in inducing their
genders to change oh wow I don't even
know amphibians had gender
apparently yeah a lot there's lots of
yeah they all there's a lot of gender
genitalia I think changes uh or
something dogs have dicks though or
maybe they swap they can swap between
genders but his animal kingdom is
different you know it's like they don't
have sea horses they can like squirt out
semen the floats in the yeah here it is
like poison basically atrazine one of
the world's most widely used pesticides
wreaks havocs on the sex lives of adult
male frogs emasculating three-quarters
of them and turning one in ten into
females so there you go so it's actually
and that's a study from uh
universities right real research but
listening theories start off with a
grain of truth right and there's there
the real concern we're emasculating
those [ __ ] frogs bro yeah now my
point always is though he takes like
he'll arrive at like certain conclusions
off of like true premises that people
don't uh want to admit or recognize like
the surveillance date he's correct on
you know what I mean he was correct on
it he was talking about how the
government's like spying on us you know
Attack Helicopters all this [ __ ] like is
true
um we also use like private defense
contractors like Blackwater now known as
academy uh of like you know veterans
that war criminals like rugged war
criminals to go and like do operations
on American soil yeah that's not a
[ __ ] conspiracy theory that's real
now if Alex Jones talks about that [ __ ]
obviously because 80 of his commentary
revolves around like interdimensional
pedophilic vampires you're gonna be like
oh yeah this guy's a [ __ ] Kook he's
out of his mind I'm not gonna believe
any of that [ __ ] I'm not gonna believe
the surveillance date all this sort of
stuff which is part of the reason why I
also thought
if I've always maintained the belief
that like if Alex Jones did not exist
the state apparatus would try to
cultivate an Alex Jones totally such an
easy slam dunk for people like Kimmel
and Colbert you know what I mean because
it's like he takes a big L and then he
gets platformed again because they can
just do monologues about how he sucks
ass so you have like billions and [ __ ]
yeah making money off of like talking
about how much he sucks right it's all
industry like so like he's just you know
they got his ass that is interesting uh
last time you were on
it was right before the election and I
asked you who do you think's going to
win Biden or Trump and you had told me
because you travel all around the
country and you've seen on the ground
people love Donald Trump and you you
predicted Donald Trump was going to win
yeah I mean I just spent like four
months at Trump rallies so I was a bit
influenced maybe so it depends though
I'm not calling you out at what point
did he say it did he say it literally
because like remember Donald Trump got
covered like you know a week before the
election like it was pretty insane like
the the sequence of events that took
place that like reignited the oh [ __ ]
covet is actually [ __ ] real or versus
is it real is it fake and like the
lockdowns are way too far like that
narrative was re-inflamed in a way that
was definitely beneficial for Joe Biden
so close to the election cycle I think
that that certainly played a role
um I've talked about this a lot like I
think that Trump's chances without
every like everything working so
perfectly against them were
significantly better than than the way
the media was casting it were you
surprised when uh when uh Biden won yeah
because I've never met anyone who likes
Joe Biden before right that's
interesting so I mean and and what's the
temperature on the street because have
you have you met a person that likes Joe
Biden since no I mean I like Joe Biden I
like dark Brandon I I don't I mean you
don't like dark Brandon why I don't know
dude he's a loser dude he's a loser yeah
I don't know he's just like a I don't
know dude hey Jack I like hair or legs
jumping on my lap I don't wanna let me
walk that back that's a negative thing
to say he's not a loser
I just don't like him
you don't like him yeah why I don't know
that's the voter right there come on
give me something look Joe Brandon Joe
Brandon is is the representative of an
awful system obviously uh this guy is
this guy is a 50-year career come on man
he's a fifth year career politician full
of [ __ ] he is incarcerated the Shadow
People he's criminalized he's like a
mass incarcerator yeah olden times he
used to kick it with with clan members
yeah he's in Iraq War uh gun uh
Enthusiast yeah he's a freaking dude 90s
crime Bill protected the crime build
which was devastating for the black
community in America like he was a big
but he's BLM now drug guy it's so funny
that he's like basically his legacy now
is like
lightly lightly undermining what Joe
Brandon did in the 90s and 80s like kind
of like making like a couple subtle
steps in the right direction you know
[ __ ] 30 years later that is a little
too late for that and even then he's not
doing would you vote for Hunter Biden or
Joe Biden Hunter Biden 100 sure yeah
because you know cracks could be legal
that's a big step for decriminalization
yeah I'm down for legalization and
prostitution unionizing prostitution
okay uh that's the first thing he's
gonna do yeah 100 I mean he's [ __ ]
awesome he's so Hunter has had a fun
time these past few years stop filming
himself smoking crack bro every time
I think that that's awesome as well
one of smoking crack don't film it yeah
I think that he's doing a lot for
visibility I think like I I've never
seen someone
so visible while smoking crack you know
and he's proud he is and I appreciate
and also crack he's the first proud
crack smoker crack cocaine the
proletarian cocaine he's not doing that
[ __ ] Donald Trump Junior [ __ ] you
know that's true no you're right he's
rugged you guys hear this guy he's right
on the ground you're right he's smoking
crack you're right he's having sex
guy yeah he's having sex with the most
35 year old looking women I've ever seen
in my entire life okay because like they
always 4chan will always be like oh it's
a psyop he's a pedophile I'm like bro
have you seen the women that he slept
with like they are so 35 years old like
there's nothing wrong with that by the
way obviously I think they were they
were probably 20 they just smoked a lot
of crack I met a dude who sold him crack
in Venice oh good yeah he wasn't lying
he showed me the text messages I also
met someone who sold uh meth to Mike
Lindell in Minneapolis Oh that's
powerful I love that I was talking to
him during the riots in 2020. Mike
Lindell is a is my favorite crack I
think I would say Michael Nails the only
person that's like worse off after yeah
cold turkey he got cut off he should get
back on meth I I heard that he got cut
off by like all the different like crack
dealers in Minneapolis like talk to each
other like basically truce real quick
ones like we gotta stop selling crack to
this guy you know I mean because they
thought he was a snitch or something
because he was coming so frequently like
there's no way this guy's buying this it
does look like a cop kind of Mike
Lindell looks like a cop yeah I doubt he
looked like I doubt he looked like that
when he was on crack though but the
voice he's so white no he but that's
like uh I need some crack right now I
need crack come on I'm not a cop I'm
Mike Lindell
would you would you also describe him as
a proletariat working-class hero because
no but he smokes crack dude well not
anymore well I thought he was a method I
thought he was into math kind of go hand
in hand yeah math is a proletariat drug
no I think I think Beth is a designer
drug
kinda it depends where you're at
here here's crackhead Mike Lindell oh
you have a photo
looking [ __ ] Bro Look at that
looks like a flasher he literally he
literally looks better than he does now
he looks hella terrifying dude imagine
yeah yeah I'm not trying to get I'm not
trying to sell it looks like a flasher
with a trench coat the big difference is
how you paying what can we do it again
Mike Lindell back on the tree first of
all he still looks like that no I'm
serious this is more plump that mustache
no one should ever have that he kept
that thing in pretty good shape yeah but
I'm gonna say how can we get Mike back
on crack or meth like how like Let's do
let's figure that out because that would
be interesting I'll just give it to him
talk to them
I won't go on the record to say once
again though that Mike Lindell was
definitely he's definitely probably one
of the few people that was like better
on crack that he's off but then he's off
crack he'll be sick if you smoke crack
again yeah I just think that that would
be maybe something that we could maybe
get a change.org going yeah
let's get Mike Lindell back on crack
yeah
um his pillows are dog [ __ ] like I
bought one as a meme I think they're
pretty comfortable I bought one I bought
one The Firm one's got good neck support
I bought one I hated it really it was 20
bucks I was like okay I'll try it yeah
he says this is the best [ __ ] pillow
in the world it's an American pillow I
used it I didn't even sleep with it I
couldn't do it yeah yeah Andrew you and
I are both fascinated with the right
wing I think we definitely uh cover it a
lot more than our counterparts in media
you in bed with them uh I sometimes will
offer them a platform every now and then
like I did with Christian Walker
um
who like out of all the Fringe groups
what's your favorite
without political Fringe are we talking
everyone also what do you mean favorite
well let's do both I mean I've always
been most fascinated by flat earthers
because that's just a complete departure
from logic and uh you know like they
don't even believe in wrong they don't
even believe in pictures they don't only
believe in images right like there's a
lot of validity to their theories
it is true I just I do love that uh the
the most fascinating part about that of
course is that like you arrive at the
anti-Semitism barrier yeah well you have
the internet Earth anti-semitic are you
kidding me
appears you're Jewish how do you not
know this but it always you know every
conspiracy theory once you once you get
better let's go do that dude think about
it people are people are lying to us
about the shape of the earth Who Lies
who controls the Earth yeah
Jews you do yeah
which is ironic because like NASA run by
Nazis before Jews but I'm so tired of
being a Jew I don't want it and Kanye's
like I'm the real Jew I'm the real Jew I
say [ __ ] take it bro I don't want it
it doesn't want to eat it good luck
buddy
don't work that way okay well he thinks
it does so just [ __ ] take the deal
he's going here he's by the way I do not
think that Kanye West is going to
recover no uh or or I do not think that
he is going to go down the route of like
actually
uh changing his mind about the Jewish
stuff because I saw another video where
he pulled a Joe Rogan you know how like
Joe Rogan loves showing his like meme
folder from his [ __ ] phone when he's
like talking about you know
he had the [ __ ] have you ever seen
this there's like an Excel spreadsheet
of all the Jews in media this
[ __ ] has a list yeah he had that
was I on the list so he basically was
saying like in a recent interview he
basically was saying I'm not gonna say
like Jewish media anymore I'm gonna say
red media and there it is without his
phone no and then he [ __ ] shows it oh
you watched it wait red yo this shit's
this [ __ ] is crazy red because all the
Jews are are colored as red all the
Jewish names oh like like uh watch this
watch this [ __ ] parenthesis by the way
and and all I'm gonna watch bro this is
him leaving the northwest basketball
game and he's got he's got Jew on the
mind okay he can't even get it out he's
obsessed dude yeah rent free
look at the top comment by the way I
haven't seen ye this happy in a long
time he looks relieved and free
good you just had to do a little bit of
anti-Semitism okay well so the part let
the man do his anti-semit reports coming
out that like um people he's been
working with that he's been obsessed
with Hitler for a long time yeah you
guys read that in terms of like power
and strategy or fashion no the he he's
obsessed he's like he's a great leader
he did amazing things for Germany yeah
like he kept mentioning Hitler in like
uh his design rooms and and to his
co-workers and there's reports coming
out now that he the the work environment
was very uncomfortable because he was
obsessed with Hitler I had to hold on to
like some of this information for a very
long time out of respect for my friend
who was working not with Kanye but other
people in his uh Circle for the longest
time but I I know I knew for a fact that
in 2018 when uh when he went to do that
Africa trip uh in Uganda specifically
when he fired all of his like security
detail and and had like a genuine manic
episode he was that was like the first
instance when I heard that he was was
like balls to the [ __ ] wall a black
Israelite extremism yeah like talking
about that sort of stuff and also which
by the way you have never interviewed
surprisingly the Black Hebrew Israelites
yeah yeah that would be good shocked
that you have not done that there's
something about me I don't think they
like
and like everything yeah Caro did it
Thoreau did it because he's British
stayed in this Mainland they see me as a
colonizer Lutheran never left just tell
him straight up first I want to let you
know not Jewish
well I don't think they care I think
they when I was a kid they used to stand
outside uh in the robes they're all I
love that [ __ ] place called Westlake
Center in downtown Seattle and like
women walk by with babies and strollers
and they'd be like you [ __ ] devil
baby he's like I hope your mom strangles
you to death I'd be like Jesus that's
what they do that's provocative they
also look like Mortal Kombat characters
which I think is very cool I saw a white
one in Atlanta yeah a white Libra
Israelite as I tried to film it and my
phone died it was the worst day myself
he's a white guy dressed like Mortal
Kombat character with six other dudes
you know albino perhaps definitely not
albino he was a or it could have been
one of those like uh you know logic type
situations where like he's like you know
a quarter well I mean there's white
people in the New Black Panther Party
yeah well let me know it's like but
they're like super weird white people
yeah like the Uhuru movement guys yeah
like they apologize before saying
everything yeah they're like they always
yeah we're a part of the referee
and it's like bro what are you doing I'm
sorry for the space that I occupy right
now yeah but I have to use the bathroom
yeah I mean dude that is so dripped out
it's like yeah
yo this is like the cat these guys are
about to spit the hottest Monty Python
remix No no no I mean dude these guys
are [ __ ] interviews they are so
[ __ ] sick dude I'm not joking at all
they are so dude the [ __ ] that they
believe in is so insane I cannot help
but be ready yeah yeah it's Shakespeare
black that like straight up dead on if
you ask uh Israelite like if Shakespeare
is black that's like yes Beethoven black
dark black like yeah uh Abraham Lincoln
inconsistent yeah it's fine because
remember that video I mean we took Jesus
from from people of color so I think is
that your that's your official stance
well I was just really fair that they
try to take some of the white folks back
uh to their I just I do I do find it
fascinating I find like uh obviously
Farrakhan uh and and like yakub yakubian
theories fascinating I'm I'm deeply
embedded in that that I mean I I don't
talk about it too frequently because
like I do have a very Caucasian
Community obviously and like I don't
want white people to like look at that
and go oh look at these crazy black
people you know what I mean yeah but you
know I I do I do watch from afar and
what's your what's your thoughts Hassan
I haven't asked you this on the Jewish
question
I want to watch uh you know what I'm
going to do a video on the he
Brew I would thanks for the idea when I
get off tour I have another I have
another thing I want to talk to you
about like there's a group of people
that keep reaching out to me I want to
do it but I don't want to do by myself I
do with you though if you're if you're
with the adult baby diaper lovers no not
the crinklers dude I got them
what's the group no no it's it's not
even no no it's like donut operator and
that other [ __ ] guy who's like like a
weapons manufacturer I think they
constantly want me to go and shoot at
their range
and I would only do it if you were down
to do it with me because I don't want to
go by myself no yeah we could do it why
don't you want to do it by yourself
I don't know I just don't you know
social anxiety yeah yeah I yeah no I
could help you I could be okay I talk to
people like that all the time so all
right so here's Kanye with a list of uh
Jews and media which I you know it's
great you know there's a lot there's a
whole world out there that's condemning
evil for what you said Okay so this
right here he's like yo you know a lot
of people are upset about you yo so
here's my list yeah here's the list of
Jews
uh Universal Studios 20 20th Century Fox
ABC News CBS CBS News Columbia pictures
uh Warner Brothers ESPN sports Fox News
Washington Post Metro go with my MTV
Music Television Nickelodeon USA Today
Nickelodeon Journal Comedy Central NBC
entertainment
um uh Google there are too many Jews at
Nickelodeon the only the only stage that
he has on reached at this point the only
part that he has to reached at this
point is like Holocaust denial like I
mean he's done a lot oh he's he's so
close yeah that's it I'm sure he
believed it already agreement thing he
was saying that he disputes The Six
Million figure I believe so no yeah he
didn't like he didn't like straight up
say that he just basically always he's
got to believe he always Ties That Into
the real Holocaust is like black babies
dying in the womb for an abortion
openings who do you think's in his ear
telling him all this easy easy dub you
think Candace and that's why I was so
upset because Candice and is employed by
Ben Shapiro
she is part of the daily wire he
literally pays her a salary and Candace
Owen is a known anti-semite she is
whispering in the ear of Kanye and he is
like doing the most for the anti-semitic
movements though like and people are
just so emboldened by this they're like
yeah no I hate Jews that's true he's
right I think like um and and I'm like
Ben Shapiro you are a [ __ ] this is a
name of coin for him he's a uncle tovian
well what I was gonna say is like I
think that Kanye is like uh you know a
media demon himself like he consumes a
lot he's like on Reddit you know he
looks at a lot of [ __ ] so I think that
there is like a organic radicalization
that happened but I think that Candace
Owens is like the spark like the
original Tinder that started the fire so
obvious because like in the he's always
talking about how like George Floyd died
of Fentanyl and it's like all the
talking points from her documentary and
all all the propaganda that she believes
in it's like he's literally yeah I've
said this before but Kanye West's
opinions actually do not closely like
they closely resemble can his owns in
many ways but the real person Kanye
West's opinions are so similar to is
[ __ ] Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas but people don't know Clarence
Thomas's like ideology well enough to
recognize that like he also has this
like weird version of like anti-black
black supremacist thought where it's
like on board with like jailing uh black
men and like uh talking about uh black
people as though specifically black men
as though they're thugs while
simultaneously saying like but also uh
we should be uh free and and I know a
lot of people who think like that
really common it's the I mean it really
is the uncle uh Tom Trope right I mean
that's what it is in a sense but this is
something crazy no no this is definitely
different Uncle Tom wasn't also a black
supremacist in the book yeah like so
Uncle Ruckus and in like Boondocks and
like uh that version which by the way I
don't even I'm not even entirely sure if
we should be discussing it and using
those terms or not but but like there is
uh there is obviously uh something that
Malcolm X has talked about as well where
like there are certain members of the
black community that and this is still a
tiny fraction that
um that subscribe to white supremacist
ideology and genuinely think that even
they themselves are are uh weaker and
and inherently uh worse than white
people Jesse Lee Peterson who I've
debated is a great example amazing I
love him yeah so he's like a legitimate
uh example of this where like Jason Lee
Peterson straight up will say
I am inferior to white people like he
says he said that yeah by the way you
need to talk to him he is so [ __ ]
funny Jesse Lee Peterson says he loves
like picking cotton or whatever yeah
yeah yeah he's he's taking photos yeah I
haven't heard that one you know like I
can't believe the [ __ ] he said he's so
funny
amazing okay
yeah there was some information that
came out that he's like he's like uh
having sex I knew Larry Elder personally
told me that Jesse Lee Peterson was uh
was actually like giving housing like
giving opening up his house to like
homeless people and then it I think it
came out that he was like having sex
with them amazing not dissimilar to uh
uh gezzy or gazi uh and and yeah some of
the [ __ ] that he was doing as well like
these are really marginalized people
that like uh oftentimes uh you know or
gazi is locked up no yeah he is he's in
prison I think anyway let's watch this
Kanye uh the list reveal so it's fire
uh what else do we have Disney ABC kids
and family YouTube ABC Kids Discovery
Network Paramount Pictures Facebook
Huntington post Yahoo Marvel Mark
Zuckerberg Paul is in time
um Touchstone Associated Press uh Pixar
Miramax HBO New York Post
LucasArts MSNBC uh Dreamworks Animation
now the thing is I skipped over maybe
about five of them because it was just
unclear on this list the red are the
executives that are Jewish dude you are
[ __ ] out of this world holy [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] you don't arrive at that
you don't arrive at that Liz unless
you've done some like that list no
that's Rabbit Hole white supremacist
that's like you 100 have gone fully down
the white supremacist rabbit hole and
you're like in forums
I've seen that list so many [ __ ]
that's unfortunate I knew as soon as he
said as soon as he said oh I now call a
red media I knew that [ __ ] Excel
spreadsheet that I've seen a million
times over was coming out dude wow this
guy [ __ ] sucks dude he is he really
like I never had any types of opinions
on Kanye West because I just saw it as
like celebrity tablet media so I never
like every time I heard about Kanye West
I just figured it was some sort of celeb
dating gossip and I always try to blend
out of that type of [ __ ] but this is
like gonna have like real life in the
pocket like this is actual real life
negative impact [ __ ] that like I'm gonna
hear some talking like I I can already
picture the interviews that I'm gonna do
like two or three months from now yeah
of just like people parroting the same
[ __ ] that he's saying and yeah they're
gonna say they silenced him because he
spoke the truth about the Jews and even
after he moves on from this [ __ ] after
the manic episode ends and he tries to
walk it back or even if he doesn't it's
going to be permanently imprinted in
like the psyche of hella people who
follow him I don't think this is going
to I don't think I think when you arrive
at that step I especially paired up with
his like megalomania his like insane
narcissism
um he has a God complex he thinks he
literally is infallible so I I don't
think he's gonna walk this back at this
point my homie Lee said that he thinks
he's going to run with Trump in 2024.
dude that would that's why I think why
is hat says 2024. your ass was about to
say that would be fire no I was saying I
think he's gone too far for Trump no way
dude they would be a freaking power no
Trump uh Rolling Stones which has like
[ __ ] embedded people in inside of
Trump's uh you know Inner Circle I guess
because they do a lot of like breaking
news coverage out of there was saying
that Trump said that he was going too
far
his son-in-law is a [ __ ] like
Orthodox Jew
not only that but Trump also yeah Trump
and Kanye are almost like two sides of
the same coin when it comes to
anti-Semitism but like Trump is like
yeah the Jews control the media but
they're doing a good job as long as
they're not attacking me type guy you
know what I mean because he loves like
like it's weird like he says the same
[ __ ] that Kanye does but he's like but
you guys are doing so well with your
money I would want a Jewish accountant
like that kind of [ __ ] you know what I
mean so like the Jews run media and it's
a good thing yeah yeah that's true well
he doesn't love the media this is
already the result of Kanye uh here this
was in LA actually honk if you know
Kanye is right about the Jews boyum TV
shout out to him I know these guys are
and then just straight and here's your
people Kanye just straight up Heil
Hitler's on the uh you know what these
guys did before 405. these same guys who
did before this they went to like
Auschwitz in Poland and like did a
similar display oh yeah I remember that
yeah nice yeah these guys just I mean
they they're like they're lost in the
sauce like these people were have gone
overboard like anyone who's anti-semitic
is like their best friend like that's
all they require as like barrier to
entry for like taking it you know they
have nothing in common and it's like oh
you hate Jews like let's just talk they
just talk shop yeah it's like yo can you
look up this quote I want to know uh uh
whatever the [ __ ] uh pretty pretty sure
these guys are not fans of black people
I'm just gonna I would say yeah yeah the
due to organize this is Hispanic
okay so no that's it we just hate Jews
and we love that about it there's
actually Filipino but the Hispanic but
the Hispanic dude definitely also I'm
telling you probably not too fond of
black people either unless they're
deeply anti-semitic like he it's all
yeah no definitely it's like Orange
County Inland Empire pools yeah it's so
I I yeah I mean there is definitely a
lot of uh the weird like Nazi [ __ ] in
Latin American countries as well yeah
those guys used to Conway around America
just like harassing Jews in like a
motorcade that's great by the way here's
the Bible quote Reverend or rev39 says
behold I will make them of the synagogue
of Satan yeah which say they are Jews
and are not synagogue
all the time at rallies oh hold I will
make them to come and worship before thy
feet and to know that I have loved the
what the [ __ ] does that even mean I
don't know but dude I've heard this
before you belong to your father the
devil that's Alex Jones has said that a
lot John 8 4 4. that's the other one you
belong to your father the devil and you
want to carry out your father's desires
he was a murderer from the beginning not
holding to the truth for there is no
truth in him when he lies he speaks his
native language for he is a liar and the
father I don't know because he's I don't
know he's lying yeah it's all about it I
want to finish this clip uh let's see
what else he says here yeah
well what I said is
hey you know
I have I've had experiences where it
felt like I was being teamed up on and I
didn't realize that that term would be
considered to be anti-semitic so I had a
mediation
um with Adidas today and I think Adidas
felt like because everyone else was uh
ganging up on me that they had the right
to just take my designs and I feel like
right now I feel like that was in
Christianity we don't say we don't say
karma we say uh you reap what you sow
and I feel like this Christians don't
say can't believe me right now because
there's two things that are happening
a lot of times when I would say oh I'm
the richest black man it would be a
defense that I would use that can't be
true for the mental health conversation
it's not just say oh you guys said it
can't be even close to True Master P no
uh Robert O'Neill if I'm not Mr the guy
who killed Osama Bin Laden no oh that's
Mick Booyah you're right no that's not
he no his name [ __ ] what is it he's like
a hedge fund guy
he's the he's the wealthiest black
American and then there's like two
Nigerian oil guys
um what I'm I'm asking for a club
oh oh you're trying to find the oh yeah
man but but that is not god-like to be
showing off so if it's not Godlike then
God will take that because it's it's all
it's all the church's money right so
what's happening right now is I'm being
humbled another thing that's happening
is shut the [ __ ] up freak idiot
an [ __ ] yeah it's a bummer it is a
bummer I was I I was just starting to
get into his music actually because I've
never really listened
Ethan Klein got into kiowa's music after
the anti-Semitism this guy's freaking
dope good ideas we do control the media
yeah yeah so you were talking about uh
black people who who are like uh racist
against black people essentially yeah
and so here's Kanye saying that uh he is
basically he sees himself as basically a
white man
it's awesome yeah you're homophobic and
so I empathize with the position
of the straight white male and part of
the reason why I empathize with that
position is because I know that I'm
headed to that position that is top
power position
thanks for the solidarity Kanye yeah it
means a lot this yes there you go top
power position baby so now what that
could be that could be interpreted in
different ways obviously like I think um
I think partially what he was saying
there you could literally look at that
in a more charitable uh position and say
like he's recognizing white supremacy
but he says I'm headed Bill is saying
like I'm gonna be there I'm gonna be on
the top eventually which is eventually
I'll be all transcend to be yeah it's
like it almost is like yeah juice
control the media but I'm mad that I'm
not controlling it like right that's
that's kind of what he's saying which is
so strange Rich enough to make his own
companies was he complaining about Jews
well not anymore I think go make a
record label not well he did
he had one that was fraught with
exploitation that was already like well
maybe maybe he needs to hire more Jews
I'm just saying
I mean uh so right Hassan so here's the
thing about that okay and I've said this
so many times at this point it's just
like I'm repeating myself over and over
again but like the reality is Kanye West
is understandably frustrated with the
way that record labels are designed he
has personal experience being exploited
by not Jews capitalists he has talked
about uh uh our no uh Bernard Arno the
Louis Vuitton guy like the French guy
who owns like the Louis Vuitton yeah and
he's talked about how like he stole
virgilablo for me that guy's not Jewish
that guy's not even [ __ ] Jewish even
though even though forward thought he
was Jewish which is kind of funny he
might he might have just because I've
read that article about forward they
said he's forward.com wrote an article
about uh Arnold and and said like a
Jewish family is like paying big bucks
to so not Jewish to pay for the the the
church that burned down in France or
whatever but anyway Notre Dame
was it no I don't my mom called me
crying when that was happening what's
going on she said Notre Dame's on fire
no [ __ ] way like Mom chill it's such
a beautiful building it is beautiful
with the Gargoyles in the Hunchback I'm
like the hunchback's not real did she
donate no no whale but yeah like the
main guy the main villain in his life is
not even Jewish but he's like still
[ __ ] talking about yeah he's so
[ __ ] close to understanding like how
these record labels exploit especially
young people from yeah you know low
income [ __ ] like and like pimp them out
for everything they're worth and spit
them out when they find the next talent
but yeah Daddy's like being like uh
convinced by white supremacists and
people who project white supremacist
talking points that like it's all a
Jewish plot to like contain and Destroy
black artists it's the it's the age-old
adage which is like uh you know
anti-Semitism is socialism for stupid
people like they can't they can't
comprehend that the capitalist system is
designed in this way they recognize the
contradictions they see it they see the
class distinction but because they're so
[ __ ] hardwired into thinking that
capitalism is good especially it wasn't
Robert O'Neil it was Robert F Smith
um sorry I got the first name right I'm
the richest American black man by the
way yeah he's a capitalist Robert Smith
so eat this [ __ ] anyway regardless you
could be have be that cool ass
[ __ ] he
yeah yeah but he's not he's not cool
he's Rich can you go to his uh you want
to know his address no Vista Equity
Partners this is his private Equity
where did he grow up his mother carried
him at the March on Washington for
Martin Luther King because I Have a
Dream speech that's Vibe if that's not
the dopest story for the that's Vibes
Where Were You Kanye during that speech
let's give that
let's let's be honest yeah I mean but
like that's great and show that too
because obviously [ __ ] no matter who
it is no matter who's a [ __ ]
billionaire yeah they're gonna be caught
in some [ __ ] tax evasion [ __ ] yeah
yeah he was a big like uh I think he was
a big advocate for the uh [ __ ] what is
it called there's a loophole is that
They Carried interest loophole but like
utilized specifically by hedge funds
that he loved uh personally because he
that's how his hedge problem is making
money um
but yeah
ultimately Kanye West loves capitalism
he is 100
uh a a completely uh brainwashed by the
black Excellence narrative that revolves
around like uh you know
picking certain people from an otherwise
marginalized community and and using
those people as like this is how you're
supposed to be see like some of these
people made it so like white supremacy
is not real not all that real or like
the only way to overcome white supremacy
is uh through black capitalism and being
very successful at it yeah Fred Hampton
obviously in my opinion was correct when
he said the solution the antidote to to
white supremacy is not black capitalism
it's it's socialism yeah um
and Kanye because he he believes in the
Prosperity Gospel style uh wealth shows
that you're morally a good person and
lack of it shows that you are a moral
failure because he subscribes to that
idea he cannot remove himself from that
equation he that's why it constantly
brings up his billions that's why he
constantly uses that as a as a way to
reinfirm his position and
um for that reason he has to single out
a group of shadowy individuals because
he himself is a capitalist he himself is
a part of that exploit exploitative
structure but he doesn't see himself as
a villain so someone else has to be the
villain it's not you know there's such a
thing as good capitalist I am one of
them and then there's bad capitalists
the Jews so that's where that comes from
like you you arrive at anti-Semitism if
you cannot comprehend the way the world
Works through the lens of dialectical
materialism you definitely nailed it
with that one I mean the guy's close but
no cigar yeah anti-cigar yeah wanna I
wanna shift gears a little bit I wanted
to ask you now moving into the midterm
you kind of have your pulse on the
people yeah like what's your what's your
feeling on kind of um
what's what's coming up for America
politically I don't know and culturally
the culture war is back on oh yeah well
I got the news machine is back on which
is like the divisive like uh mainstream
media outrage cycle on both sides it's
back in full swing it was pretty silent
for like six months I don't know why it
just other [ __ ] was occupying people's
minds I guess Ukraine yeah yeah
something took people out of like
domestics uh social conflict but now
it's back uh freaking
I'm not freaking is like the lamest
Segway or anything
uh freaking not like the [ __ ] like every
time I go on YouTube It's Like Jesse
Waters talking about like trans women in
sports yeah Colbert is like won't stop
talking about January 6 like it's all
coming back yeah so I I made this call
uh as soon as I recognized the writing
on the wall that like Brandon was going
to win most likely and I said that this
was going to be exactly like uh the
gamergate era internet where like
everyone was going to turn to the usual
like team sports in politics where uh
you know I'm a republican I'm
transphobic I think trans people are are
scary and they're somehow like you know
queering our children and they're bad in
their grooming on the Republican side
that's all they [ __ ] care about
um and then on the Democratic side they
would go towards like uh you know
microaggressions and whatever the [ __ ]
going on that like they need to clean
their own ranks or or whatever
um the Liberals haven't really performed
as much as I thought they would on that
front but Republicans are fully invested
in that cycle yeah and they're they're
bringing it back in a very big and very
meaningful way I mean you have so many
anti-trans bills like so much
legislation that is cut out in the state
Transit and fetuses that's everything
yeah I feel like Libs kind of had their
year
in 2020. yeah we had the the January I
just think that like that whole Arrow
you know was like like with the
corporations you know turning like super
anti-racist for like six months like
forcing that [ __ ] on people in in the
middle of the country and all that so I
think now there's a big moment for uh
like right-wing [ __ ] happening yeah
pendulum yeah it's swinging back in the
other direction what's your feeling like
it feels like in the past decade or so
crime is a big one oh before I forget
sorry yeah even though crime is
decreasing which is interesting you're
you're now we're at a stage where like
literally even the [ __ ] comp troller
running for like a local position in
Arizona is cutting Willie Horton ads
like that used to be something that you
know popped off in the 90s and then we
got the you know crime Bill shouts out
the Joe Brandon yeah and then for a
while it was like well that's a little
[ __ ] up that you're saying so openly
that black people are criminals and
thugs that you know need to be uh need
to be over policed now uh as a
punishment for all the corporate
messaging uh I think that uh local media
and and the national news cycle is like
creating has successfully created this
narrative that like every [ __ ] big
city is crime ridden and there's a
massive crime wave which by the way
there's no empirical evidence for it
there's no cases for that crimes are
more active than the homicides no uh
like boosting like
oh you're talking about cars the Kia
boys and [ __ ] no I'm saying like an SF
like like this there's more stealing
than ever like there's more like just
like busting into cars bipping and [ __ ]
like that overall though yeah overall
it's still consistently lower than yeah
it was at the heat of like the the crime
it will never get as bad America will
never get as dangerous as like the mid
90s and that goes for every city like if
you look up homicide stats in 94. it's
double the worst like New Orleans
Detroit these places had like like
Juarez Mexico level like homicides for a
time period well a lot of these places
still have incredibly high crime rates
it's just that you oftentimes just uh
assume that it's only happening in
California or New York when you actually
look at the evidence when you look at
violent crime
red states are top 10 every time with
like some exceptions I just think in
California and Oregon and Washington you
can get away with like a hell of petty
crime yeah like because there's more
relaxed court system so I think that's
what where they get the G the ammunition
to do like the whole like this this uh
yeah the west coast is there's like
videos of people running into like CVS
and just grabbing even like Arizona if
you could caught with drugs in Arizona
you could caught with like a little bit
of anything you're going You're gonna go
to jail yeah which is [ __ ] up yeah and
it's good that you shouldn't go to jail
I agree I mean I'm not I'm not saying
it's good but really we're not sure this
is crime is not a crime yeah
Arizona Montana South Dakota like some
of these like States they are extreme
Judicial Systems like you're going away
for whatever yeah and it's really [ __ ]
up and it also plays a role in their
economy you've got places like Angola in
in Louisiana right Louisiana State
Penitentiary first documentary there oh
really not for all gas no breaks but
when I was working for my the Diaries
one my no it was about uh the Angola
Rodeo oh you did that which is where
they have like trustees which are like
well-behaved inmates they're able to
like perform out Rodeo people who should
have already like you know uh had gotten
back into society that they keep there
well behaved for well-behaved slave
basically no literally that it's
actually a labor prison no no they call
it Angola for that reason like it's
named after the Angola Plantation which
is named after obviously not simply
named after but it's actually on the
same ground yes as the largest school it
is in Louisiana yeah yeah it is it
literally they pick cotton like they
actually really yes like what the
children today yes but I wanted actually
like it seems like in the past 10 years
maybe more there's just been less
emphasis on policy and more emphasis on
culture wars things and um that seems to
just be intensifying and I'm wondering
is there an like off-ramp or do things
just get more tense like I just don't
know where I don't think it'll be as bad
as 2020 next mid next election you know
in terms of civil domestic conflict no
because
that was like a drill
we've already done it one time you know
what I mean like I don't think there's
going to be like proud boy antifa street
brawls like there was in 2020 I think a
lot of things kind of peaked and
coalesced like the volcano kind of
erupted already you think so yeah for
sure riots plus January 6. like I feel
like both the right and the left have
their sort of like Supernova moment I
don't even think about January 6th I
think it was Charlottesville that like
kind of kind of uh put so prominently
white supremacy yeah on the main stage
and a lot of people even on the
Republican side were like yeah that's
that's too far I guess difference being
is a lot of people who are at the
Capitol thought they were there for
Trump and like doing the right thing
because they were consuming so much
misinformation whereas anybody who went
to Charlottesville is like an uh actual
white supremacist yeah to ascribes but
I've never seen mobilization like that I
think that was a historic mobilization
in comparison to like you know obviously
nothing in compared to like Madison
Square Garden yeah you know the famous
have you seen that no the American Nazi
movement in Madison Square Garden in
like 1935 I believe uh I don't know
there was well look it up during the war
yeah yeah uh they were there was a big
there was a big Nazi movement in America
there was a big like that's why you have
Nazi compounds here in California too
yeah um still uh but anyway they they
were really into that [ __ ] that's that's
a good photo that cam just posted in the
Discord check that damn that's a lot of
[ __ ] I think it was like 30 000
or maybe even more than that those are
they're all that was dirt those are all
Nazis like straight up this is during
World War II so you got to be really out
of your [ __ ] mind damn I mean you do
now too but you know what I'd like to do
to that building right Dan
no uh
dance now just give them a Stern talking
too well there was a Jewish guy though
and the cops beat the [ __ ] out of them
yeah uh anyway yeah but that's
interesting to think that you think back
to Charlottesville you're saying you're
shocked by the mobilization at the right
I was shocked by the mobilization to
unite the right and I know for a fact
because of unicorn Riot and other groups
that like infiltrated these shout out to
them servers yeah shouts out the Unicorn
Riot they do great work
um we know for a fact that they were
literally like oh [ __ ] these people are
doxing us these people are actually
showing our faces and we're getting a
lot of pushback in our real lives we got
to go back into the Shadows yeah and I
think that cut their mobilization
genuinely which is why unite the right
two was nothing you know what I mean and
that really that really pushed back the
the mobilization of like open out and
about white supremacists in America yeah
and then January 6 was like uh
I don't even think January 6 was as big
as a like a like a you can't do this you
went too far for a lot of Republicans
they still ride for it yeah I just don't
think they would ever do that again
it took it too far how many of them got
locked up didn't work nobody wants to go
to jail you know they didn't accomplish
anything and also like the response is
just gonna be different you know like if
there were to be protests again they
would just do what they did in Portland
you know bring out like uh federal
troops to just dump expired CS gas on
everyone like yeah the tactics are now
understood just like right the Capitol
Police would know how to respond next
time right a lot of things happened for
the first time in 2020. I see so you
that's interesting so you think there'll
be a simmering down of uh I think
I don't not the biggest spill more fan
but it's cold Civil War is what it what
it was called I think the culture war
will continue online will be the real
Battlefield as it typically is but I
don't I can't see there being Mass
Street mobilization again what do you
see again I I ask this because you're
have this like access to so many people
like real salt of the earth kind of
people like what I don't know but you
should like what what do you see
is there some kind of Trends or forecast
that you see happening on the ground
that like you're interested or scared of
or no not right now I mean I haven't
like been in the field for a minute
really like I haven't really filmed much
in the past two or three months why just
I filmed a lot I filmed for like four
months straight so I had like six videos
loaded I just been editing at the house
right taking it easy yeah before tour I
mean I have to like you know go on the
road for months and then the movie comes
out the day tour ends so I'm just
kidding I have a lot to look forward to
wow I don't really want to like uh get
all sad you've been working hard and
you're about to enjoy the exact fruits
of your labors fruits of Labor nice I
think as far as like on the ground
mobilization goes you're right uh when
you when you are uh genuinely facing
consequences or when you see others like
you with like-minded individuals
genuinely facing you know consequences
of the federal government you're going
to think twice before mobilizing on the
streets true the other component is that
they're not ideologically motivated they
are just angry you know what I mean it's
it's almost like uh
I've talked about this before Chapo trap
I was talking about this a lot as well
with like mass shootings happening in
America there is
there is a a genuine snapping moment for
a lot of people but they end up
redirecting their anger towards the
systems on representatives of similar
hierarchies in their lives like women
because they think like women are
responsible for all the anger and
animosity feel insults do this yeah uh
or they think their manager is
responsible for the animosity because
they're like that's a microcosm or a
reinforcement of that same structural
inequality that they feel every day and
in a similar way these guys are like
behaving like medieval peasants where
they they see a lot of anger resentment
they they feel a lot of resentment and
anger and the television man is telling
them it's immigrants and the television
man is telling them it's like you know
queer teenagers or whatever so they just
redirect that anger and animosity
towards like parent-teacher conferences
and [ __ ] like that where they can make
minor differences in their immediate
lives and feel accomplished we saw a
version of this within the liberal
movement when Obama was president when
like liberals would get together and you
know draw the pitchforks out obviously
I'm not making a moral equivalency
between like [ __ ] recasting a voice
actor or whatever because they were only
25 black uh versus you know what the
[ __ ] these psychos are doing in like
Michigan for example where they made
this 13 year old girl like take down her
mural and like made her cry because they
thought that it was demonic
um
but but it's it's a it's a place of
powerlessness there's no mechanism of
pushback oftentimes that mobilization
and that mechanism uh if you don't do it
through labor unions obviously from the
left to side which are non-existent in
this country pretty much
um on the right wing side this
mobilization comes from fascist
mobilization like uh you know brown
shirts and like militias and
um and a lot of those people do not have
like the ideological motivation they're
just [ __ ] angry they're not like
they're not even aware of what they're
angry at they're just angry and the
television man is telling them to be
angry at this thing rather than angry at
the actual problem right
um
so for that reason I feel like their
their mobilization is is uh diminished
yeah totally right partially also
because of the federal pushback and you
know pushback that they saw because they
were shocked yeah like they a lot of
these people felt like you know whether
they openly stated it or not they
recognized that that they were entitled
to a government that was always going to
side with them
right and all of a sudden when the
government does inside with them they're
like shocked they're like what the [ __ ]
you're treating me like
this is my government I'm entitled to be
able to go into the capital how dare you
[ __ ] prosecute me for this I'm doing
a patriotic thing so that I think makes
them second guess as well so you are
correct on that for sure that's good
actually that's encouraging I'm glad to
hear that because I guess I I'm not as I
know I just I guess I'm pessimistic bro
but I have I want to change each subject
a little bit Yeah in April you were in
Ukraine that was like a whole different
approach for you going to like a kind of
a war zone I mean you've never done
anything like that right no I never and
that was right as the war was breaking
out right yep what was I mean was it
scary being there were you afraid yeah
have you ever feared for your life like
that and and in the course of your work
yeah worse in the U.S during a lot of
[ __ ] I mean I was in leviv on the
western side of you know Ukraine so like
they're the extent
of the bombing there was like at that
time was a field Depot and like the
outskirts of town I mean aside from the
air raid sirens going off every two
hours and having to go into a bomb
shelter like three times interrupting
your sleep at night it wasn't that scary
I mean it was more just interesting to
me also as a journalist you know what
you're walking into you know I think
it's I get more scared when spontaneous
stuff would happen in like a familiar
environment like at somewhere like in
the U.S whereas I'm going to Ukraine I
know there's a war so it's not like I
pull up and I'm like what the [ __ ]
going on here you know already have that
like journalistic like helmet on Vibe
you know yeah so you went there and
things hadn't really gotten bad because
I'm looking at like clip like people are
still walking around living their lives
yeah and I think now this was supposed
this was post like the first bombing
operation that happened in Western
Ukraine this was post Invasion so this
set they like things have normalized at
that point as best as you can
um now things are really bad in Western
fronts uh again because Russia is using
uh suicide drone attacks uh and and have
I think like reduced their power
capabilities down to 30 percent Yeah by
striking power plants and like other
parts of their infrastructure what was
the vibe of like in general well it was
interesting is like Lev is like much
more of a Western European city and as
you can see it's like cobblestone
streets like old school it kind of looks
like it's in like Paris or Denmark or
something so I was surprised I had
envisioned more like Soviet block style
apartments and like sprawling uh brutal
infrastructure uh I mean brutal
architecture but yeah man it was like
very interesting for sure people were
trying their best to live their lives
like people were refusing to stay home
from work like refusing to let the war
impact the things that give them uh
normalcy this is almost the sense of
purpose peace of mind and I didn't
realize that you know because you think
about a country at War you assume
everyone's living in this like
shell-shock state of fear and panic but
I mean like these people were doing
their best to keep things moving bars
are still open the craziest part about
this is that this existence is actually
identical to the existence of people
living in like occupied territories in
Afghanistan they also are doing the
exact same [ __ ] where they're like yeah
what am I going to do I'm supposed to go
to [ __ ] school and I want to see my
friends you know like I want to like
have my morning coffee I want to read
the paper I want to go watch like my
favorite YouTuber like the regular
people and the war is external and
people try not to let it get inside them
yeah but at this point I'm sure normalcy
is becoming a lot harder than it was
yeah when you shot this I think human
beings have a tremendous capacity to
adapt to any circumstance that they have
to deal deal with and like normalize no
matter what kind of Oppression or
struggle that they're facing yeah are
you surprised by kind of the direction
of the war there uh what's going on
there yeah yeah for sure what did you
expect kind of to happen after your time
there
um I expected it I don't really know I
haven't been following it as closely as
I probably should but what I didn't
expect is like the Ukrainian territorial
defense you know which is like pretty
much any male above the age of 18 had
all drafted my passport was issued the
same day that the Russian invasion
started and so they would like pull me
with like machine guns and like check my
passport and have you ever been to
Moscow have you been in Russia they're
giving me more like smoke than anyone
else wow because you know oh I saw a lot
of like American
um like jar head contractors wow no not
even matters they're just there for Love
of the Game
War tourists but like proud boy looking
like [ __ ] chuds like but it is is
that like who are the people that go
there and fight just for Love of the
Game there's a lot of like dude what do
they believe in I mean I I like I like I
mean I love democracy but you're saying
they look like proud boys like what are
they there for it just seems a lot of
them I think are just addicted to like
the adrenaline combat or something they
just okay so if you're a veteran and you
can't have a a life of normalcy in
America and all you know is [ __ ]
combat because in your most formative
years you've been shot at when you were
in the karengal valley you're going to
be like all right I wanna I wanna keep
this going this is an opportunity for me
to keep it going like my [ __ ] with my
boys so they go over there and just
volunteer the Ukraine Army just accepts
them in and also America has no problem
with citizens going there and fighting
too the whole thing is kind of
interesting why would they they said I
don't know that way I mean they
experience The Operators out there to an
ally to an aligned nation that we're uh
giving a lot of weapons to and I mean
they're already sending contractors out
there it's not like the [ __ ] cias not
out there operating you know what I mean
they're yeah absolutely there someone
has to train these guys to use the the
weapon system that they're sending over
yeah so these are just War addicts you
think who just love [ __ ] killing
people there's a combination of that
yeah yeah I think there's definitely
contractors and you know War tourists
there's a lot of that that happens when
you're a nation in war constantly and I
mean America yeah I mean I'm a
journalist you know I like to be in a
tense you know situations so I can
understand in a sense like sort of
chasing uh the energy of it but I do
think it's pretty weird that's front
line [ __ ] though yeah you know what I'm
saying I just imagine that the war
Taurus being like an amplified version
but more self-serving and Amplified than
like a typical War journalist but I
don't chase tragedies around but I'm
just saying I just assume that they love
that feeling of like being really in the
mix of a conflict and I think they
probably love talking to people at home
about it and like having that like
heroism and going before they feel like
Heroes yeah yeah I mean a lot of people
in the military too you know like maybe
not in LA but in most small towns in
America if you walk into a Waffle House
in uniform like people stand up and clap
for you they do you got a standing oh
yeah and the Waffle House oh the dick
riding is crazy if you went to a bar if
you went to a country bar in Bakersfield
right now with your fatigues on like
every girl's talking to you you're not
buying a drink really yeah I don't know
if that would work with it the dick
riding is crazy people don't like when I
say this but I'm like I I'm I'm like so
I'm
first of all I'm not like a military
simp I don't get the whole thank you for
your service thing this isn't like World
War II you weren't drafted you signed up
to do a [ __ ] job you're being paid
you're there the job you know what it
was I mean nobody think me and my answer
or nobody think the [ __ ] cashier is
not good I mean
the output is not good your job is to
literally door bust and like [ __ ]
terrified 14 year old brown children
okay I'm not gonna sit here and act like
that's what I'm saying you're not good
for my freedom you're not killing Nazis
you weren't forced into a war with
nonsense
you're bombing Villages from a drone God
bless you I put heavy with veterans like
I have a lot of veterans in my community
I I talk to Veterans all the time like
there's incredible [ __ ] organizations
that I I work with from time to time
like about face and like you know
Veterans for uh piece like there are a
lot of Veteran organizations uh that
that genuinely are conflicted about
their service and recognize that it was
traumatic and awful and what what they
did and to them I have a tremendous
amount of exp uh respect but if you're
like one of those Jarhead dudes eating
crayons and then you [ __ ] you know
destroy the lives and homes oh man I
missed the burn pit and get me some
sniffs a burn pit down there like I feel
in
it bad because like they have been duped
into the poverty draft for sure and like
they've been duped into poverty rap but
like if you're gonna be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] about it and you're gonna be
like oh dude what the [ __ ] like uh you
don't understand me giving literal
[ __ ] Ziploc bags of cash to a
pedophile warlord defended your free
speech in America if you're gonna come
out you can sleep at night no no that
guy that guy has no idea where the [ __ ]
America is on a map shut the [ __ ] up
yeah I mean there's two minds of it like
obviously they exploit poverty and and
force people into war and they come back
traumatized and suicidal and PTSD yeah
and these [ __ ] need help and
they don't get help but at the same time
I'm not gonna suck your dick bro for
doing a job I'm just saying yeah I'm not
gonna do it it's not even a good time
idiot when I say thank you for your
service like when you're in a circle and
everyone's like thank you thank you for
your service thank you for service and
then they look to you like come on bro
I'm just I'm like Larry David situation
yeah that was Chad Hanks by the way did
you know that the oh [ __ ] that character
the veteran in that [ __ ] Epic episode
is Chet Hanks how crazy is that a friend
of the show yeah yeah
I talked to chat every now yeah go ahead
you want to say something uh I was it
like a an event in New Orleans East it
was like a Vietnam veterans event I
didn't realize it was
p-o-w-m-i-a brother by the way those
guys are more I mean it's not wasn't a
valiant service data but they were
drafted yeah they were forcedure
there was some drunk ass Vietnam veteran
and I walked up to him I was like thank
you for your service because it was just
me and him and like waiting for the
bathroom or something he got real close
to my face and he was like I'm tired of
[ __ ] hearing that
and I was like okay all right well I
didn't mean it I was like what do you
want me to say to you and he's like say
that thank you for keeping me free oh
and so now yeah not enough Ho Chi Minh
was coming Ho Chi Minh was coming for us
bro thank God Vietnam so he was like
you're not stuck in my dick hard enough
so now I say it to every veteran thank
you for keeping up that's crazy that's
for me thank you for keeping me
individuals
you say that for real absolutely because
you know it just hits them right in that
spot yeah
thank you for keeping me free
you better [ __ ] say that seriously
absolutely zero percent chance gun to my
head I'm not saying what's like I wonder
what can if we could engineer the most
over-the-top gratitude to it yeah
the only time I get on my knees is to
suck off a hero veteran brother thank
you for making my life possible brother
yeah how about that we at all be
speaking German right yeah
we're speaking Chinese if it weren't for
you thank you sir thank you
children all right what's like uh
I don't care he's like yeah he went
there he went to Saigon and like you
know had sex with like a sex trafficked
woman for a little bit and then like
came back and he's like yeah man I
really did a [ __ ] insane job like
thank you yeah thank you for keeping me
free like there's still children like
Vietnam is such an interesting country
because like uh they claim to be
Communists there's some inconsistencies
there obviously but there's some good uh
uh social programs overall but they
[ __ ] love America they they're
actually a bigger America simp than
Israel yeah they love Michael Jordan
they love Israelis is only like by the
way Israelis
are not America's Sims they only love
presidents that love Israel which is
funny Obama they say Obama hates Israel
which is so funny it's like Obama gave
38 billion dollars to Israel I was
living in Israel during the Obama era
and these [ __ ] they love Trump
hate Obama
they love Trump people straight dropping
n-words like crazy they don't understand
the context like the old school Israelis
but they drop n bombs with the hard ER
like nothing on the Obama name
is real very similar to America in a lot
of ways I'm not even gonna say but some
people yeah I'm not even gonna go there
but yeah no they [ __ ] hate him and uh
they love Trump you're about to get
double canceled bro watch out what I do
the n-word well I didn't do it I didn't
do it don't say anything don't say
anything about Israel
during my cancellation J posted a
Jerusalem Post which is the number one
English paper in Israel did a write-up
about me yeah and they were not too fond
of your your takes oh damn you've had a
rough couple days
yeah the good thing about it is like my
fans some disappointed understandably
because I got banned again but everybody
of my fans like isn't mad about what I
said the con because they know like they
know you know so that that that makes it
easier on me is this gonna be the first
thing that comes out
um no they've made shows you guys so
this is coming out on Thursday we're
pre-recording a lot of stuff because
we've been gone for a week so we're
posting our Halloween special today
Saturday yeah
and then we have a show
oh we already filmed the show for Monday
that after dark yeah the one that we
filmed yesterday will come out on Monday
this will be a few confusing we'll be
out on Thursday yeah
um do you need to go a song it's been
two hours yes
definitely yeah
I have uh I have a stream that I had set
up anything else
anything else I want to talk about I
mean there is one subject we didn't
really cover too much uh about five
minutes well you gotta go yeah he has to
go too so you up to something
interesting my mom um she wants to hang
out oh that is interesting what's more
important
she wants to hang out I thought you were
going to be like take her to a nice
restaurant I'm a member of Soho House
you're probably doing good let's let me
ask you a question you do it you're
doing pretty good financially I'd say at
this time right sometimes what do you
mean sometimes
the patreon's insane merch is probably
insane so what sometimes
well sometimes I'm doing so well he
doesn't even give me the merch anymore
really he's like he he stopped he's not
asking me to do merge we don't do
gifting anymore yeah I mean sometimes I
spend so much on production like with
this cartoon that I like I'm down bad
for like a month until I you know really
I may ask how much you invested in that
cartoon like 75 000 okay yeah
you're richer than that bro come on yeah
don't act like that
you there's no YouTube money though
why oh because everything is all
monetized yeah yeah
there's no way you can monitor your
monetization on YouTube is [ __ ] bro have
you watched these [ __ ] videos what do
you mean but you got hooked up with that
has that guy helped you that I hooked
you up with thanks yeah
but I think but like I know yeah what is
this yeah you're on Twitch what do you
care wait I'm not gonna bust my nuts
or not I can only I can only pull this
lever so many times okay I have a robust
YouTube platform for the record uh one
point I think seven million 1.7 million
Subs 1.07 million so I'm not gonna bust
my nut for a 1.7 million
have a little fun we're just going back
and forth man yeah okay but um so yeah
congratulations on all your success
we've been huge fans here forever yeah
thank you guys you guys are so nice to
see you doing well out there
uh and and and if you don't come on my
show before we go on tour I'm gonna be
like Andrew changed up I'll come on he's
so close to calling you big time bro
yeah he's big timing us understand you
be careful you had to reschedule like
eight times like I'm like losing hair on
my way over here I'm like what the [ __ ]
this was very hard to nail down but I
think it was probably because you were
sick yeah but we did it we did it it was
fun too it's good to see you yeah thanks
good to see you guys soon man I love
your content bro you're probably my
favorite content creator love you guys
on YouTube right here bro I'm just
saying you do what I do I'm not
impressed by what you do wow wow
just ask him to be on leftovers like in
the mix yeah wow how often do you get
covered like every other day a lot yeah
yeah like they had all three downloads
yeah oh [ __ ] you probably you're
probably creating new variants Delta and
regular yeah you're like jair bolsonaro
bro yeah so kova Champion now I don't
get it anymore now because I'm just
strong yeah your body your immune system
yeah the guy the guy in [ __ ] uh
Sacramento was right yeah a few years
ago you have the lungs of an 80 year old
yeah no it's all good if a new uh
pandemic comes out though I'll let you
guys know because I'll be first to get
it thank you bro yeah give us a heads up
that would be useful but anyway Channel
5 dot news catch Andrew on tour yeah
he's coming all over the country to town
near is that not right sometimes
sometimes are you not in all over the
country oh you said he's coming all over
the country oh yeah
will there be come will there be come uh
no
no come that's a bummer audience members
might come
Channel 5 dot news
um Andrew is [ __ ] all over the
[ __ ] place yeah and uh thank you for
being here Andrew we love you thank you
for having me
thank you Hassan
oh yeah uh the Double interview yeah
thank you guys well yeah fun times
you're the last guy we did was liver
King so yeah I know yeah you guys like
him
he's a marketing guy I liked him yeah
you might want to hang out with them
dude stinks I would 100 hang out with
them I I like I don't want him as a like
a hangout guy more than what are you
gonna do with liver King like what do
you do work out shoot guns work out uh
[ __ ] well you know he's not feeding
you any [ __ ] real five tanks no you
bring your own food bro I would not eat
with them
you're on the rain bro where you get us
a burger like I'll I'll eat burger patty
yeah some fat bison Burgers you know
what I mean I'm on I'm not hanging out
with Liberty
[Music]
not that he's asking but just let people
know all right DM me recently thank you
guys thank you God bless uh oh he did
yeah wait hold on hold on what do you
say he said that he started a new
Twitter and his I think it the Tweet was
like that you're sub Primal and I'm
Primal but I said that about me yeah
dude he loves your ass he does he's like
he doesn't like I'm [ __ ] Primal baby
that's why let's go you didn't like my
soy ass fat [ __ ] body yeah I disgust
him what are the questions about [ __ ]
Barbarian brother I started on Twitter
last night aiming for 100k followers
before I leave Dubai can I please get a
shout out what a loser
gunned ahead Hassan The Hunt is Primal
h3hu Productions is so proud
what up [ __ ]
but did you promote his Twitter no good
thank you I didn't see it you know it's
too late now
yeah I'm not proud
whatever all right fellas yeah uh been
real all right yeah all right bye bye
dude oh yeah man it's good thank you
guys
[Applause]